think the biggest challenge I think it's
really confusing for like young women
because you're told to like
do what men do yeah and we're not men
yeah yeah I would say that's the biggest
challenge okay um I've said what I think
is the biggest challenge for men what do
you think is a big challenge for men
hoes how so
um like I just think that they're
getting finessed
more than previously yeah like more than
ever okay in what way
like like there's so many guys well
minus the ones there's okay okay there's
two there's two types okay okay there's
the one guys that are like the top
percentage they're living their life
they're having a good time because they
just have unlimited access to like women
and they're like they're they're good
right second type is like the guys that
kind of get used for their like money
and resources because the girls don't
really like like them like that and I
would say like they it's like they'll
marry a girl and then she'll leave and
take half that's 50 of marriages so I
would say that like a bad marriage can
literally ruin a dude's life yeah and
then there's a third type that just are
like very lonely and I would say that's
their biggest problem
and and I would agree with you though
the purpose I would say like men do lack
purpose nowadays and they're very
confused at like what they're supposed
to do so like before you know
masculinity was celebrated but now it's
punished almost that's the thing and
it's really sad because I I'll see you
guys on my show sometimes they'll come
on and some sometimes I call them simps
you know like
and
I do and I'm but like I'll see them and
I see that they want to say something
and they're like conditioned yes and I'm
like why are you like like you don't
have to say this because the girls are
here yes like like and it makes us lose
respect for you because we we know
you're full of [ __ ] we know we can feel
we we know when we're on [ __ ] we know
when you're on [ __ ] like I think you
know I think the summary of what we're
really saying is that women are being
women are and have been trained slash
indoctrinated to suppress their feminine
energy yeah and to lean into more
masculine traits yeah and men have been
encouraged and brainwashed to suppress
their masculine energy I think I think
it's so interesting that toxic
masculinity is a is a is a phrase and
toxic femininity is not right just just
that fact just the fact that there isn't
even the it does it does exist but it's
it's funny it's the opposite yeah but no
nobody says it it's not it's not a known
phrase no I've had a couple girls on the
show send me like they say I should do a
show topic on it's kind of popular in
like the the weirdo space I don't know
like the liberal like that okay yeah but
it's it's but they when they call toxic
femininity they when a girl like does
the traditionally feminism so of course
so it's all inverted they have it but
it's like the opposite ah okay okay yeah
this is the things you want to be
submissive yeah
it's an inversion because again I think
so much stuff we live in this weird age
of people really really hating biology
yeah right there's like this assault on
biology and this notion that the way we
are naturally wired is wrong I mean down
to the fact that
a man you know people literally saying a
man can be or is a woman and vice versa
like the most
you you can't kind of get more basic
biology than that let alone in terms of
actual behaviors and things that people
are attracted to or put off by and
interests you know they're always trying
to in certain Fields well we need to get
50 50 gender split in this or and it's
like bro you can't have
freedom and have Liberty and also expect
to get these equal outcomes and
everything because men and women are
fundamentally different and some people
just view that as a problem that needs
to be fixed and I'm like that is not a
problem it's not just okay it's good the
difference is and that Dynamic we're
designed to be complementary to one
another and this is the um
I think most girls would want to do what
men do and actually I didn't do it they
don't but they but they've been trained
to say that they do like okay like the
boss [ __ ] like I I have no I have a
business okay yeah and this is the thing
I'm like I swear to God most of you
would not want to do this [ __ ] I'm like
and and this is I Outsource decision
making to do it's like I literally
because I was like no because I will
think about a decision for like 10 years
and I just can't I don't know like I
just think this is how we're wired and
it's stressful making decisions all the
time and it's like even the way I do it
like it takes a lot off to know like I
can go to my dad or go to my manager and
like they kind of like do it you know
what I'm saying and so it's like
I'm like I swear to God all of these
boss chicks whatever you would not want
to do this like you would not yeah it's
so interesting because you're
comfortable and happy to say that yeah a
lot of women feel the same way yeah but
the programming will not allow them to
say it yeah just like there are a lot of
men who feel a certain type of way about
things you you kind of suggested this
with some of the people you've even had
on your podcast yeah they they they feel
like they can't say that thing because
they've been told it's misogynistic or
that it's sexist yeah so everyone's
operating from this position of
inauthenticity where people don't even
want to just say what they themselves
are even
like what what what they generally
believe or where their natural
inclination is because they've been told
what women have been told you know they
they feminists like to make it seem like
they're totally cool with women just
being Homemakers and you know looking
after the kids again they're really not
okay with it right like a lot of a lot
of feminists do not they don't like that
they're not really in favor of that
choice per se they like that word choice
but actually when a woman makes that
type of choice they'll be the ones who
are attacking did you see the tick tock
I posted well I posted on Instagram too
with my friend Ally I don't think so um
so it was trending on Twitter okay and I
asked my friend Ali she's a housewife
and I was like show me a ring and she
showed him this big rock and I was like
how did you get this ring she's like I
submitted to my mail like yeah and she's
just like talking about how
um she's like yeah you could go work for
a boss or you could go work for your man
like why wouldn't she want to work for
your like and it got such a backlash
that it was trending on yeah I was
trending on Twitter and I'm like why are
you guys mad I'm not saying there's like
one way to do things like my mom worked
it wasn't like you know she was like a
homemaker but I'm just saying like
at some point like we don't like making
decisions we think we like making
decisions
like yeah the brainwashing is deep man
and when you think of the people who
orchestrate this stuff it's like cool
they've just been able to essentially
double their double their tax base and
Smash down people's real wages over the
decades and now it's it's not this stuff
is not accidental this is the thing you
know people think all this stuff is just
uh it's like no this these these these
things over the decades are very
intentional and planned and effective
sadly you know it's very it's very very
effective you can tell when something's
extremely effective is when people are
essentially repeating propaganda without
even knowing its source or the fact that
it is propaganda that someone gave them
like when you hear people even repeating
certain phrases and arguments it's like
so that came from the top you were told
to say that phrase you don't even know
that you're which is why oftentimes when
people can't even explain what they're
saying like they're saying that they
believe something and I'm like you can't
even explain it you just keep repeating
the line you've been told to say but you
can't explain it when I challenge you on
it it breaks down very very quickly
because you haven't gotten past the line
we saw this actually we don't don't want
to talk about the the scam damage
necessarily but you saw this over the
past and a half years with all the stuff
people were saying in 2020 and 2021 and
they're just repeating it and repeating
it like they've been told what phrase to
say and you ask one question and they
just get angry because they haven't come
to that conclusion themselves it was
just like okay this is the phrase you
repeat this is the slogan this is the
motto and everyone just walks around
like an NPC saying it and I think that
the exact same thing
is happening here even with you know a
strong strong independent woman strong
independent like
there's no again there's no phrase a
strong independent man like that's not a
raise right that's strong and
independent I have Alpha even the fact
that it's it's just yeah it's just one
of those things that's been repeated
repeated repeated and young women now
feel pressured or like okay that's what
I'm yeah that's what I'm supposed to do
so instead of Leaning into any type of
femininity they now just think they need
to compete and be like men in every
Avenue and I'm like most of you do not
work hard enough I I swear I'm like you
would not want to do like oh God they
would not want to do like half the work
that I did to like like get you know
like I'm like you guys can barely get on
the treadmill like how how the hell are
you gonna start a whole business like
okay yeah I honestly don't think surely
Diane
Rebecca
uh where does it go from here Pearl
what's next what's next um
with what as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible